on the leftovers this is intense your
character has been put through more than
it's almost like a coyote kind of it's
like a dog at this point coyote
Roadrunner you've been poisoned you've
been shot and then this season in the
season opener your character puts a it's
an index is one of most intense scenes
I've ever seen on television oh good
seriously you you put a plastic bag over
your head and try and kill yourself and
they show it in real time we just have a
still from it because our sensors said
it's too disturbing to show the whole
thing yeah and I was thinking I was
watching that scene and I was thinking
oh my god what is it like to show up in
the morning and they tell you here's
what you're doing today you're taping a
bag without duct tape we're actually the
first shot first you know first day of
work for season three so literally the
first six in the morning or something
you know I sat down had to strap a bag
over my head see here I show up at work
and it's like today you're gonna ride a
goat it's all Andy's gonna be dressed as
a cowgirl you're gonna eat ice cream
every day it's pee-wee's Playhouse you
back yeah yeah this seems like a very
intense role that you show up in the
morning and you have to do that scene
yeah we did it I think we did it a bunch
of times you know and there was all
sorts of safety concerns you know they
wanted to run an oxygen into the back of
it or whatever and then I realized oh
it's just a bag you know I could just
tear it off my face but what if you pass
out and the better someone would know
the truest the art crew would be like
let's go get us some coffee
I know good one buddy no these suckers
right here yeah he's being funny let's
go get some coffee
yeah maybe ones by design
you